good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Sheila Jackson Lee is
famous in Washington for being the
single most obnoxious member of Congress
now that's a title that as you can
imagine has many contenders but Sheila
Jackson Lee stands alone don't you know
who
she once screamed at a flight attendant
in the first class cabin on a
continental flight I am congresswoman
Sheila Jackson Lee where is my Seafood
meal
in the 1990s during a visit to NASA
Sheila Jackson Lee demanded to see the
flag that astronauts had planted on Mars
when gently informed that no human being
has ever been to Mars because it's very
far away Lee flew into a rage she
accused NASA of racism and pointed out
her membership on the quote science
Committee in Congress and so on we could
spend the entire hour on Sheila Jackson
Lee stories and it's tempting on Capitol
Hill she's known as the queen and not in
a good way
but what's interesting is that nobody
ever talks about the congressional
district that Sheila Jackson Lee
supposedly represents
it's mostly Inner City Houston and it
could use some help Lee's district has a
poverty rate almost twice the national
average for all the usual markers of
civilizational decline high crime bad
schools low social cohesion drugs
now Lee has quote served in Congress for
nearly 30 years but it's hard to think
of a single thing she has ever done to
improve the lives of the people who
elected her she doesn't seem interested
instead Sheila Jackson Lee has devoted
her entire political career indeed her
entire life to a single cause shrieking
about white racism that's what Sheila
Jackson Lee does for a living here's a
selection
institutional racism and systemic racism
taints and spoils the way that America
treats in one instance African Americans
and other instances minorities the
dastardly impacts of white nationalism
white supremacy and outright racism
racism is a national security threat
racism is a national security threat
racism is a national security threat
institutional racism does exist and
until we accept that we will not finish
our job we will not elect a chief bigot
of the United States of America our
system is such that it then allows
Americans people to act in instances in
a racist manner
racism you see is a national security
threat it's a national security threat
really Sheila Jackson Lee tell us how
racism is a national security threat
speak slowly we've got plenty of time
but of course you won't do that she's
got no argument she's got no facts she
doesn't even have a sincere belief in
what she's saying
it's absurd and she knows it and by the
way she'll jacksonally doesn't want to
protect a country she despises from
National Security threats why would she
want to do that no that's not the point
what she's doing here every day is
leveling a racial attack a blood libel
against an entire group of Americans
while simultaneously pretending to be
the victim of attacks from that same
group
stop hitting me she howls as she punches
you in the face
it's such a common tactic at this point
used constantly by Al Sharpton by the
ADL by so many others that you may not
even notice it anymore but it's still
disgusting it's still immoral it's still
divisive here's Joe Biden doing it and
finally
we're confronting the stains of what
Remains The Deep stain in the soul of
the nation
hate and white supremacy
you know there's a tough through line
of subjugation and with Slave people
from our earliest days
to the Reigns of radicalized Terror the
KKK that Dr King being assassinated and
the violent deadly Insurrection on the
capitol nine months ago it was about
white supremacy in my view
speaking of blood libel because that's
what it is protesting the 2020 election
results is the same as slavery as the
KKK it's the same as murdering Martin
Luther King it's all white supremacy
declares Joe Biden without defining the
term now you may recall when Joe Biden
said that you probably dismissed at the
time is ridiculous as the rantings of a
senile partisan and of course that's
what it was
but you should also keep in mind that
Joe Biden did not say that by accident
it wasn't an ad-lib off the cuff no his
staff signed off in that speech they
wrote it they read it before he read it
and they wrote it for a reason when the
president of the United States
identifies a threat to this country his
many federal agencies the biggest in the
world swing into action to neutralize
that threat that's how the system works
as Joe Biden's staff well knows
so in fact when Joe Biden Likens you to
Al Qaeda or the clan
it's not a small thing at all it has
implications
so here's Sheila Jackson Lee from last
week in a not unrelated clip calling for
the renewal of the Patriot Act watch
I remember after 9 11 when we all worked
together
to ensure the protection of the American
people
through the
Patriot Act and dealing with the fisa
courts we work together
because truth is important
now that's kind of strange if you think
about it so why would Sheila Jackson Lee
a self-described liberal find herself
last week praising the secret government
courts that liberals once opposed
passionately on the grounds that those
courts could be used to destroy the
constitutional rights of Americans
without anyone knowing about it secret
courts
liberals were against secret courts and
now the chief liberal in Congress is
strongly for secret courts what's going
on here why
well because those secret courts turn
out to be a highly effective way to
Silence the Critics of the democratic
party to silence those so-called white
supremacists Joe Biden's always yelling
about not all of whom by the way are
white you don't have to be white to be a
white supremacist you just have to
oppose the agenda
and of course Sheila Jackson Lee knows
that very well and that's why she wants
to renew the Patriot Act indefinitely
and there are enough dumb Republicans
that she may be able to
but Sheila Jackson would like to go a
lot further than that Lee is just
introduced a bill called the leading
against white supremacy Act of 2023.
now it's not an exaggeration to say this
single bill would do more to criminalize
speech previously constitutionally
guaranteed speech than any other piece
of legislation that has been proposed in
the entire history of this country
that's not an overstatement at all and
to prove it we're going to read directly
from the bill here it is quote a
conspiracy to engage in white supremacy
inspired hate crime shall be determined
to exist between two or more persons at
least one of whom published material
advancing white supremacy white
supremacist ideology antagonism based on
quote replacement Theory or hate speech
that vilifies or is otherwise directed
against any non-white person or group
end quote
now nowhere in the legislation is the
term white supremacy or white
supremacist ideology ever defined
of course it's never defined it's left
open it's subjective anything can be
white supremacy
but the bill does specifically point to
something called replacement Theory
white supremacist ideology if you engage
in either one of them you go to federal
prison
possibly for a very long time
so all that's required under this piece
of legislation which has not been
laughed out of Congress yet all that's
required is that your political opinions
quote could as determined by a
reasonable person motivate actions by a
person predisposed to engaging in a
white supremacy inspired hate crime
so what would qualify as a felony under
this law well virtually everything but
among them would be pointing out the
Democratic party politicians including
Chuck Schumer the leading Senate
Democrat have longed bragged that they
are flooding this country with
immigrants in order to change the
demography to maintain political power
for themselves they've said that many
times they've written it they've bragged
about it on camera but if you notice it
under this bill you would be criminally
responsible for the violent acts of
people you have never met
and you would go to jail for terrorism
now
what's most interesting about this bill
is that it's race specific
nothing in Sheila Jackson Lee's
legislation would apply to say black
Supremacy or Murder sprees By people who
aren't white supremacists the massacre
in Waukesha for example so that means
that Democratic party politicians can
continue to say whatever they want with
impunity the First Amendment still
applies to them but not to anyone who
doesn't vote for them so that's the
definition of tyranny it's horrifying
it's a direct attack on the Bill of
Rights on our core freedoms guaranteed
by the U.S government for 250 years we
shouldn't be surprised by this however
because it's consistent with what Biden
has promised as promised since the day
he got into office and the promise was
that race Blind Justice which is the
entire foundation of the rule of law in
the west has been for centuries is done
the new model South Africa that's the
new model South Africa a country we
never talk about because no one wants to
admit what's happened there over the
past 29 years
but on the basis of that Biden tried to
allocate Farm Aid on the basis of skin
color a federal judge blocked that plan
but it has not stopped the Democratic
Party
because no one's reputed the idea no one
on the right has been brave enough to
say no the federal government can never
award
or punish on the basis of skin color
that is immoral and is contrary to
American law
and because no one has said that
Democrats including Sheila Jackson Lee
have decided that their opponents are
terrorists and they're terrorists
because of their race
and once you're a terrorist what do we
get to do we can take all your stuff we
get to seize your assets
it shouldn't surprise you that is
actually unfolding in the state of
California always the Leading Edge of
lunacy watch this
these economists
alongside us over this past year to come
up with potential estimates for what
reparations in the form of compensation
or cash payments can look like for
African Americans that 500 odd billion
dollar number represents the state of
California's maximum culpability for
racist redlining practices and that
number represents the state of
California's maximum liability it is not
a final recommendation coming out of the
task force final recommendations do not
come out until July 1 of 2023.
now everything about this of course is
bad and wrong not just in practice but
in principle but in practice it sets up
an incentive that the whole country is
going to have to Grapple with fairly
soon we've already been told that you
can change your sex your immutable
characteristic just by wishing and so
men can become women women can become
men why then can't people change their
race that's a sincere question that is
waved away is ridiculous but it's not
any more ridiculous than changing your
sex in fact it's the same
so under laws like this there is a huge
incentive to change your race because
you get paid for doing that what are we
going to do about that
but what's interesting and sadly sadly
predictable
is that as politicians in California and
the rest of the country decide how
they're going to loot the treasury the
name of racial Justice the communities
they supposedly serve are falling apart
in real tangible measurable ways people
are dying axios for example reports that
carjackings in DC have risen for the
fifth straight year
ask anyone who lives there that's the DC
Council candidate who was carjacked in
broad daylight a year ago
a vehicle stolen Friday may be linked to
multiple crimes in Northeast including
the murder of 19 year old Devin Brewer
there was a drive-by shooting on Central
Avenue Northeast both victims survived a
lookout for the same Highlander went out
over police radio the plates on the car
appear to match the burgundy Highlander
used to carjack a D.C Council candidate
at gunpoint Nate Fleming was at a gas
station on Nanny Helen Burroughs Avenue
Northeast he says when the suspect
pulled a gun he gave up the keys then
went into the convenience store to call
9-1-1 he says one of the guys came in to
stop him from doing that chasing him out
of the store
so instead of doing anything about that
in DC the leaders are doing what Sheila
Jackson Lee does shrieking about white
racism as if that's the problem or even
a related problem of course there's
nothing to do with carjackings as for
actual carjackings that are killing
people making taxpayers leave DC
terrifying everyone in the city
well the DC city council has just passed
a bill that will lighten the punishment
for carjacking as well as other violent
crimes
so here's what you have at the same time
that Sheila Jackson Lee would like to
make it a quote hate crime a felony for
disagreeing with her
her
compatriots in DC and across the country
are making it easier for you to get
killed by an actual carjacker
anarchot-tierney is the name of that
system and it's spreading because no
one's saying anything about it subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight